assistant professor at the University of
Vienna he's an expert in Dynamic graph
algorithm and also State graph algorithm
one of the things that he has been
pushing forward successfully is the use
of
vertex specifier in Dynamic and static
graph problems so yeah go ahead thanks a
lot thanks a lot for the intro to other
one and thanks for inviting me it's a
it's an honor pleasure to be here okay
so today I'm gonna talk about
some work on Dynamic wrap approximations
and we'll look at this object called J
trees
so a lot is going to be about telling
you what are j3s and how actually to get
efficient algorithms to operate on these
objects
and probably towards the end I'll tell
you a bit more about how to maintain
these objects dynamic maybe not a lot
but I will go into detailing to what are
the main ideas okay so this is Joint
work with Lee Chen who's the Georgia
Tech a grad student of Richard uh Monica
ansiger my my previous advisor
um
[Music]
okay great so I will motivate this
through the max for problem
and let's look at just directed graph
let's assume we don't have weights for
the sake of Simplicity weights could
show up because we are doing
specification but uh the input graph
always think of it as being unweighted
okay
from now on even though like our results
we generalize for weights and I will
discuss this morning
as usual n will be the number of
vertices then will be the number of
edges
and I have these two distinguished
vertices smt that I call source and
Target smt
so what is uh what is the flow
so a flow is a mapping
on the edges so a non-negative mapping
on the edges and we say it's feasible if
the amount of slow that you push along
each Edge
is at most one and we know such flows
would be integral actually so if you had
a capacity instead of one you would have
C over here or U over e over here
then another condition is that you have
flow preservation in a sense that
for every internal vertex so for every
vertex there is not a red vertex
the amount of flow that you
send
so the code goes in into this vertex is
the equal equals the amount of flow that
goes out okay so this is the first
generation contrary it is capacity
constraint
and what is the value of the flow this
is the net flow out of s
so you just look at
what is the amount of value you're
sending out of us here and that doesn't
really make sense because I don't have
edges in this direction right okay so
there's just some simplification with a
lot of generality
then what is the goal do you want to
find a feasible SD flow of Maximum value
okay so this is
a textbook problem and it has been
studied for years
so I'll do a short survey here I'm gonna
just focus on directed animated graphs
and I will not talk about capacities
here that's why probably this is a bit
sparser and sorry if you don't see your
name over here and you've done some
progress on that
so this classical algorithm of Ford
focusing in 15 in the 50s
if you have unweighted graphs then we
know it runs in them in time okay
because we know the max of values at
more than just amount of flow leaving
the source right it's important
okay and then there was these classical
results by karzanov and even antarjan
this gets the m to the 3 over 2. and
then Marjorie was actually the first to
use electrical flow so bring this down
so 10 over 7
there were some subsequent improvements
this is what uh this is by kataria Leo
and sidford and then recently there is
this breakthrough Max to algorithm these
are all directed graphs by the way
and they achieve an almost in your time
algorithm for computing Maxwell's
interactive graphs
okay so there's also been some interest
in from the approximation point of view
so the first result now these are sort
of subsumed except this one by the exact
algorithms
so for in approximation here I mean
higher currency it's not the entirely
high accuracy what people call
optimization but this is something like
OnePlus Epsilon and you you're allowed
to have Epsilon poly Epsilon dependency
in the running time okay it's not like
log one over Epsilon
uh so this is m to the for the three by
um
the Cristiano canner Marjorie Spearman
and tank
and then this was improved later by
Sherman and
Kellner
Lee orrakia and sidford and then Richard
Pang uh
Factor over here it's a polynomial
Factor
and there are many other well-sided
variations of this problem you have
capacities in planar graphs we have seen
also a lot of work on on flows or
variants of Max flow
and also in distribution parallel
computational model
yeah so the question I'll try to
sort of address in in the stock is the
following
so what about the dynamic complexity of
Max flow okay so what do we know about
Max flow
in the dynamic setting okay so let me
now you've seen the slide probably many
times so let me just Define for those
who haven't seen it
I'll spend some time here
so like you'll have some fun so what is
this Dynamic algorithm so essentially
you have this graph on the left hand
side the edges are getting deleted okay
or inserted so in this case you have a
deletion so you can think of a dynamic
algorithm as a box that does some work
for you when you say okay something got
deleted in Minecraft and at any point
you can also
so every time you have an insertion and
then also you take this update and you
pass it to the dynamic algorithm this
magic box and then at some point you can
ask okay what is the max flow value in
this current graph okay the one that has
processed all the
updates and you should answer something
okay you should give an answer to this
query
and what is the goal the goal is to
maintain this
this optimal value either exactly or
approximately depending on what you
allow
and two quantities that you really care
about are the following the update time
which is the time to handle these Edge
insertions and deletions so I'm assuming
that vertices remain intact
problem
so I would say I would start by saying
that in contrast to many other problems
like you you saw zoil's talk on matching
and also if you you've seen a talk on
Dynamic shortest path so there is a
multitude of papers and a lot of
progress on these questions
unfortunately on the max low regime I
would say it's it's very limited and we
don't understand the problem at all in
my opinion
at least in the fully Dynamic setting
okay so what is known for exactly so
there there was this um
momentum of proving condition lower
bonds and that guard had I think the
best result in terms of like sparsity
regimes in the store bonds and then uh
showed that if you want to maintain the
six exactly that there is no hope you
cannot get truly something about three
times okay
now one thing you can do and which is
sort of uh immediate from the literature
is you can compute a cut specifier so
this is this you should think of this of
this sort of as
persifier like benzo cargo type h
classifier right you can compute a cast
specifier and maintain this dynamically
with polydog overhead yeah this is this
paper by Abraham and others who does
this
and then you can just compute you
maintain the specified and compute the
max flow on that so that would give you
m versus n right so you can get a speed
up you can reduce the edge count
so let's sort of immediate from that
result
now in terms of the fully Dynamic
setting and here none of these results
actually works for
directive graphs where was the
specification idea would be oblivious
right sorry
education result would be Lucas yes I
think it would be oblivious there are
some adaptive ones but then I think the
approximation ratio is higher
oh okay so the question was whether this
this result is oblivious or not I should
have repeat it the question
and yes so I think this is against
oblivious adversaries if you want and
gets adapted but I think the
approximation is is higher as far as I
know I mean Aaron knows he's in one or
Yan is known yeah awesome awesome
uh yeah like many people can confirm or
deny this yeah
yeah
okay so what is known in the fully
Dynamic setting so there are uh so far
as as I'm speaking I I don't know what's
what's happening so people might have
results but but as I'm speaking there
are these two results these are known
and kind of similar in the in the in
spirit so the first one is actually
what's doing is is maintaining some sort
of a single tree cut specifier flow
specifier that achieves uh very good
running time but very bad approximation
and today I'm gonna tell you something
about this result which is our result
um where we do nearly logarithmic
approximation okay and and to the
two-thirds of date time so we get
something like a truly sub linear this
is for fully Dynamic so both agencies
are deletion
so the reason there is also work on just
looking at partially dynamic
uh an incremental or decremental uh it
doesn't seem to to be easy
and so I had this work uh with Monica
where we show that for exact you can get
something
on
uh undirected graphs
and for our proximate which is
non-trivial for example if your if your
graph is is dense
and
um and also you can get Squirtle fam
sort of if if you'll offer small
approximation but this is incremental
insertions only
and there is also a work by uh van
vandebrandt Leo and sidford Aaron
um so here they actually managed to
bring this m to n still directed grams
but the caveat is that this works for
capacity graphs and for Max fluid it
seems to make a big difference at least
in the incremental setting
uh capacitated versus uncapacitated in a
static setting I would say not so clear
but in Dynamic setting it does make a
big difference so also if you look at
both papers and and the techniques this
one is just doing some something very
easy this one is the employment
enterocol in methods so
okay so there's this Gap in terms of
complexity
okay so today I'm gonna try to tell you
something about this result
and the idea is to just yeah maintain as
the final promise maintain some graph
approximation dynamic
okay are there any questions about these
results so we'll stop here for a bit
so the result in the middle this is for
directed or undirected because you see
there's no kind of propagate
but until it's a yes and then for when
when it say yes then it continues to be
yes
so that was the idea to not repeat it so
yeah yeah I didn't explain it but yeah
and so
okay great
efficiency
okay so what are these three based graph
procrastination so this has been a very
powerful theme in static algorithms so
the idea is that you're you're given a
graph
and you want to approximate it by a tree
and why would you like to do that well
many grab problems are very easy on
trees and well not all of them but a big
majority right
and then
what you also want to do sometimes is
try to actually map this tree solution
back to the original graph and you will
see in some cases why is this useful
and some examples in in graph algorithm
design
or for example spanning Forest if you
have a spanning force of the original
gravity you know the graph property you
preserve is connectivity if you do a BFS
or shortest path tree you preserve
distance from a source
if you have Gomery who trees they
preserve all pairwise estimation cuts
this hard Eagle was operated here also
know that boruto or frt trees though
those are expected very large distances
and Monica talked about this in in our
survey
and those prescription is also a class
of graphs and it's like actually a class
of trees that are useful and we will see
why they are useful for us too but in
this talk I'm really going to be
interested in in objects that preserve
either the cut or the flow structure
okay
and by by this I mean all the cuts right
and you might ask why don't you use
Gomery who trees well I I don't know how
to maintain them dynamically so but yeah
that would be
too but it's it's not now it doesn't
seem trivial
okay
I will relax this a bit and I will not
be looking at this talk at least I will
not be looking into
approximating a grab by a single tree
but I will look at approximating and
grab by a bunch of trees actually
and you will see what what this means so
this will become more clear
so it's not going to be like just one
specifier but a bunch of specifiers and
they'll all be guaranteed that one of
them is good
so that's the idea
okay before I tell you what these graph
approximations that we're going to look
at are really are so let's just
uh Define uh first look at this notion
of graph embeddings
okay so I'm giving a graph G
okay so here I have capacities I could
have avoided this but it's fine and I
also have a graph H now age
uh is it a grad that sits on the same
verdict sets it doesn't have to be a
software
okay and then I also have some capacity
function for both of these graphs
so what is the embedding of g into h
so an embedding is simply a
multi-commodative flow which I can view
it as a vector
and I have a
flow for each of the edges of G
okay
and this flow gives me a way of routing
the capacity of that edge
in in the graph page
so for example in this graph if I take
this
two vertices this one and this one then
I can route I can Define such flows just
by routing long shortest patterns
that's what an embedding is
and I say that so I can Define this
that's no problem it's just the
definition but now I want to to have
good embeddings and what does it mean to
have good embeddings I want to have
embeddings that when I do this sort of
mapping between flows from here to here
I wanted the load or the congestion that
I incur in this in this other graph is
small
so I have this notion let's let's look
at this notion what is an Alpine bed in
g into h
so I say that g is Alpha and variable
into h
if there is an embedding Gap there
there's this multi-commodative flow on
the edges
of G
such that for all edges in age now
the amount of flow that I push through
an edge so see this hatch could be used
by many other edges I look at all the
edges that cross this cut so if I cut
this Edge
this will correspond to a cut here right
and although these edges that cross the
cut will use that edge in their shortest
path
in the tree right unique shortest path
in the tree so I wanted the amount of
flow that goes through the attach is at
most Alpha times the capacity of that
edge
that's what's called an alpha embedding
okay
so what is root Prime
a u Prime is some uh these are
capacities it's a capacity function on
the edges
still used here
okay so this is U Prime
so it's a title
there are many typos probably so you
should ask
yeah so this is a u Prime
okay so now one question is so this is a
this is a two-way thing right you can
say I take two graphs and I said I want
to embed g into H and I want to embed
also H into G and then I say their flow
structure is is sort of good up to some
approximation sorry
and and the vertex sets are identical
right yeah the vertical vertices are
identical in this one okay so now uh how
can you make this so I call this age I
like to call this age a better flow
Network
what does it mean everything I can route
in G I can route an age this I can make
sure in a in a trivial way right so for
example if I'm allowed to this is like a
network design question if I'm allowed
to pick this this U Prime myself right
I'll just compute all these loads of
these edges so the load is the amount of
flow that goes along an edge and age
right and I'll set that to be the
capacity
okay so then I can route everything in G
I can route in age with
with no loss because of this capacities
that I said but the question is now that
I've set these capacities now this Edge
has capacity say this is unwanted one
but here it crosses the support sorry a
pretty dense cut right
so it will have many edges going through
that
so you you see it immediately that and
actually in fact
this is a spanning it's spanning tree of
this one so you see it immediately that
there is no hope to actually get a
single tree that is good for all Cuts
right
if you insist on spanning free if you
insist on other trees then things can be
done but it's beyond the purpose well I
guess it depends where you want your
Prime to be right
sorry
it depends what you want U Prime to be
yeah I I think regardless of how you set
you prime you will have a very bad badly
congested batch
yeah yeah that's fine I as I said you
can you can make g embeddable into age
but the other way around you also want
age to be compatible
so then you want to say the flow
structure of these two graphs say it's
kind of the same up to some Alpha Factor
but then your Alpha has Infinity if you
do that
okay is this notion of embedding clear
okay so now we're we're going to look at
this result so this will be the starting
point of uh our Construction
and uh in fact it will blow so sort of
it will build up incrementally so we'll
start with this result by Redken then
we'll go to madri and then finally I
will tell you how to actually some ideas
how to make this dynamic
okay so now what is this tree base
approximation for flows so essentially
there's this result but I Reckoning a
breaker weight 2008
and shows that for any given G let's say
you don't have capacities for now but
you can have capacities
you can find a Converse combination of
spanning trees so these are spanning
trees
such that every G is one embeddable into
egi this is Trivial to set right because
I said you compute the loads of all of
this
um
trees right and then
okay this GI is a TI sorry like a typo
so this G is one embeddable into each TI
and then there is also an embedding
of egi into G or TI into G such that for
all edges
now you see the convex combination of
these embeddings is good for every Edge
yes
yes a single one actually
a single one a single log login Factor
okay so this is the hotel Logan is
hiding that
so you can actually get a tight login
here but then you you you don't you
cannot choose spending trees you have to
use something else
so that's the idea so all of these trees
are really not good flow sparsifiers in
a sense but combined they are good and
combined using this convex multipliers
okay
so what does that mean in terms of
solving on the trees so like you solve
on the trees and then you average yes
yes yes I will I will actually now have
a cat represent interpretation of this
foreign
core result sort of uh shows some
Duality between distance and cuts in
networks and we will see why as I will
explain some of these constructions
and it has found a lot of applications
this is by far not a complete list
it was used originally for business
routing then I think the best
approximation factor for main cut by
section is based on these things
and you don't know how to improve below
that
one problem with this so we are
interested in fast algorithms right so
one problem with this is running time
so it has a horrible running time at
least uh quadratic a m
and what's the reason well the reason is
that actually you you need them of these
trees
to
uh to have this conversation so the
support of this
distribution is at least them if you if
you do this
and even if you implement each iteration
in linear time in the number of edges
this running time cannot be avoided
okay so it's a great tight result but a
bit slow
so now
Madrid had this fixed and this was
mainly uh motivated by this developments
in a LaPlace and solvers namely the
ultra specifiers of Sigma and tank
so he said that okay what what what
about doing the following instead of
approximating G with this bunch of trees
I'll approximate G with a bunch of more
complicated objects which are called J
trees but then these are so useful for
me to do some cut-based approximation
over okay
so let me tell you what is a j3
so now
so you have this so it's a union of two
graphs in a in a certain way
so you have a forest which you call F
and that's called the envelope so these
are all of these edges that you see
sorry all of these trees that you see
over here are
crazy that belong to these four staff
and then you also have an arbitrary
graph C which is called the core.j tree
then you want that the number of
vertices in the core is at most J
okay this number of arbitrary vertices
and then
you also want that for each kinetic
component in the forest for each of
these three they have exactly one vertex
in the chord
and observe that if you have a one tree
this is just a tree right
and two three is a tree yeah yes because
then you can have many parallel edges
and stuff yes
okay so now you you may ask why why is
this desirable in terms of like
approximating graphs by these objects
well think for example you can think of
many things but you can one one example
is I don't know Max flow right
so if you say want to stop Max flow in
this in this graph so what and you you
are interested in finding the max flow
between this vertex say and this vertex
over here
so the max flow is Trivial until you hit
the core
right because you just need to follow
the unique path until you hit the core
right vertex on the same here
so essentially the time complexity
of solving that problem reduces to the
time complexity of solving the problem
in the core so that's that's the gain
and the gain is that this query is small
right
okay so now modri proved the following
he said Friday graph G you can find the
convex combination over these J trees
such that
okay now I'm doing here cut because
we're going to work only with cuts I'm
doing a cut interpretation what you saw
before I know that in each of these
trees the cuts are dominating in each of
these J trees and then in expectation my
cuts are preserved up to this Factor
okay
and this comes combination are the the
support of this distribution now is
going to be only M over J so that's
where the M squared over J comes from
okay so I have in each iteration I'll
spend near linear in the number of edges
I have M over J J trees
and that's how I get M squared
so the talk of touch upon
you can actually interpret this result
as j3 is being vertex parsifiers
individually so again we are not doing
specification on a single graph but but
bunch of graphs which is a bit different
but the idea is that uh if you if you
view these vertices in the chord to be
the terminal so the cuts you are
interested in then it's very easy to
just solve the problem on the core and
then you can actually lift it back to a
cut in G by just attaching the force
okay because you you so it's never it's
never the case that you will cut some
Forest here right even for from a flow
perspective so if you're interested in
in sending flow between core vertices
you will never use this for us right
so the initial problem just contract the
core and Route on the tree
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so or like you do so what's called this
this routing to a core vertex and
routing to another core vertex and then
you solve the problem
yes
one basic question so the capacities on
the edges of the day trees are one right
you had this notation of U Prime no
actually
in capacity is no no they are not one so
these these edges will will actually
uh just take the capacity of the
underlying graph Edge that you have
because these are spanning for us right
these ones you will have edges that
exist between core vertices plus edges
that you map you will see now
so they are not one no
these are even if your G is
uncapacitated this would be capacitated
okay
and
yeah so the the main motivation why
madre did this is that
he wanted to design fast algorithm for
cut based optimization problems like Min
by section sources cut and so on and so
forth now some of these results have
have been improved by other techniques
but
the important point is that it's also
served as one of the key blocks for
actually speeding up Max law in this
work of Sherman and Kennerly or Rick and
sit for me
and bang as well just to understand
though like yes I mean M squared over J
doesn't sound much faster than M squared
unless J is pretty big right so okay
yeah I'll get to that so N squared over
J is kept at the squared of M right so
if you set J to B squared of M you will
get m to the 3 over 2.
but the the good thing is that what
Madre shows is that you can recurge on
this
we don't know how to record on this but
I will get to that
and yeah I'll discuss this in the next
one
yeah yeah
I keep forgetting uh yeah
okay
you should think of Jane as m to the
point nine then it's 1.1
if you apply it because
yeah okay so what is one thing one one
uh
one really cool thing about this is that
once you have computed the distribution
over trees you don't have to work with
all of them actually you can sample
login but that's enough
okay
and why why is this true and this will
be useful for us
this is true because you sample
according to this context combination
log NJ trees and then you know for every
steaming cut there must be a j3 that is
within two alpha
and this just works for my by Markov and
then you apply Union Bond overall cuts
okay so this is important because once
you've computed the distribution you
don't need to work with all of them you
can just sample
plug in of them and work on them
according to this context multipliers
and again just going back to Daniel's
Quest on on recursion so Madrid shows
that you can actually recurse on the
cores now
so now each chord is some arbitrary
graph but it's smaller so what this G3
allows you is a vertex reduction
okay if it's dance you can do cast
person file
you can bring down the number of edges
dumped to doing proportional to the
number of vertices and then you recurse
on these things
and of course you can do this the
running time will be better you will pay
in the approximation Grant
so it's going to be almost linear but
then you will probably pay something
Supple in normal approximation
okay so let me tell you what we show
finally
uh we show The Following
so if you remember such upon stock that
he gave at the book and he was saying
that one of these Court techniques
vertex classification what requires is
disability of taking a verdict that is
not in the core or taking a vertices not
the terminal and making it a terminal so
taking a non-terminal Vertex or a
non-core vertices and making it like
putting it into the core okay
and why is that because all of the other
operations like update query all of
these reduce to this single operation if
I update an edge I'll make them points
of a Vertex Terminals and then this Edge
actually will appear in the core and I
can actually just go to the core and
update it accordingly delete or insert
or change the weight or whatever the
same with queries okay
and you will see that soon so what we
prove is the following so if you give me
a graph and now you give me a single j3
because I I told you if you sample login
of them you're happy I'm happy I will
preserve all my cuts so I my goal is to
actually show you how to do it in a
single j3 then you just repeat the
argument for login of that okay
so you if you give me a single j3
that is good approximation uh to to G
so there is some data structure that
will maintain a now a slightly larger J
Tree
okay but it's just some constant Factor
so this means I will add more vertices
to the Core
which is still a good approximation
and you support the the following
operations but r2g okay so oh sorry up
to J and whenever you exceed this J you
will repeat so you will repeat from
scratch okay so this this is capital J
operations
so this is a structure I can build in
time MN or MN over J
and I can also add the terminal in the
summer price time so this is actually
crucially used amortization these are
not worst case guarantees just to
mention that
and also when I whenever I work on the
core I know that the core has size at
most J it can have most size at most J J
squared right but I will just apply
Dynamic cut specifier as I said in the
beginning so I I have no loss there just
one plus Epsilon
so that's what we we actually prove
foreign
I want to also mention this
and so this is very interesting in a
sense and it it shows up in this
I mean chicken and egg interactions in
algorithm design
so for example you can use a similar
data structure but not exactly this one
you will need definitely more work so
this is not as a black box but similar
ideas from this one
to maintain this problem this subroutine
called Dynamic minor ratio Cycles which
is close to doing
maintaining a dynamic loss responding
Tree on a graph
in this result of
breakthrough result in Mexico and almost
inerta so another interesting thing is
that here the
graph is undirected
but here you server directed
National problem
and also
so it is funny also in a sense that we
use this to to actually do Dynamic Max
flow and this is used to to solve static
Maxwell right
yeah so is there Distribution on age
implicitly here because like the
approximation needs many trees right so
when you say h approximate HG
uh you just pick some random age yes
well I'm maintaining the random age
and so so what does that guarantee mean
over time is it like even on expectation
for that random object over time it
always yes yes yes if you can maintain
the object yes I think that should work
yeah
yeah so I'm happy to discuss more more
about this and uh definitely sushant can
say more and probably aren't too but
uh yeah so this is sort of used inside
but they also need more work
okay so how to actually use this result
to to do Dynamic Max flow so the once
you have this result about that
determinal this this is just it becomes
trivial okay so the idea is the improvis
this thing you do the following you
computer J Tree base approximation for
cuts of G
and this could have many traces we
discussed now you just sample login of
them so you don't need to work with all
of them
and you initialize the data structure
from the previous slide so whenever you
have an insertion of the deletion of an
edge you take them points you add them
as terminals
okay and then you can process actually
the insertion or deletion of that in the
core itself
because the edges that are between
terminal vertices in G will appear in
the core this is by definition of of how
the embeddings will work
this will crucially rely on that okay
and to query s and t if s and t are not
given in advance to you you do the same
you add the endpoints of terminals you
add s and you add T and then you just
query on the on this parsecore and you
return them in
okay so this this becomes essentially
trivial once once you have this hammer
okay
okay so let me tell you now how how we
compute this
um cuts three conspiracifiers then how
we could compute j3s and then I will
briefly mention how how to maintain
well this trade-off I will skip be
because you can work out the running
time and be convince the vocabulary
uh yeah but yeah was this all oblivious
or this is all oblivious actually you
can make it against adaptive but the
running time has to go up to four over
five or something
but not deterministic
actually the other result is a
tremendous thing but yeah I can I can
tell you
okay so how do we construct these three
based graph approximations
so let's look at the the first the
simplest one called the spanning tree
embedding okay so I'm given a graph G
I have a spanning tree of G now I can
compute this capacities right so I
compute this capacities this capacity is
just the load that you put
say fire out in the Tria log to the
shortest paths so every Edge I look at
the shortest path between this end
points in in this graph T and and then
after I've done that for all my edges in
G I say okay what is the capacity what
is the load that all of this all of this
embedding has put on this Edge and I put
it capacity to be accepted that okay
now you can write down this ties as
actually solving just an LP
so you want to minimize this Alpha and
then you know well this this will be has
quite a few variables but yeah
so the goal is to actually install this
LP and add it to sort of bond Alpha in a
sense
okay so what you will do is you you will
sort of do some sort of motivated weight
update so you don't want to solve
because yeah as I said like there are
many variables here so it's not clear
but now in in modulated update what you
get and this is actually a simplified
version of that
so what it turns out to be very
important is the following so if you can
solve this sort of dual or Oracle
problem
where where given a graph G I can find
in if you can find in near linear time a
spanning tree T of G such that
the load is good on average
okay so the the total load is good on
average here
and G is embeddable into T that you have
for free
just by setting these capacities
then actually then compute a complex
combination of M trees that two alpha
embeds
uh this comes combination into G okay
is it clear this disclaim over here
so if you solve this sort of dual
problem
and again again it's it's not it's not
entirely correct
it's missing something but what's saying
that if you can give me a tree that is
good on average with respect to load
I can do M iterations of uh mwu or multi
weights update to get down this this
guarantee into worst case guarantee
amongst this entries
that's what I was saying right this
averaging one
[Music]
turns out that
that suffices for you to find
it why because you can convince yourself
that average stretch and average load
are
actually the same up to some scaling
parse this yes
the first thing this one yeah yes if it
can find a spanning tree
if I can find a near linear time
spanning tree T of G such that the
average load is good
then
and if G is embeddable into T then I can
compute a complex combination of entries
such that this approximation Factor just
goes
oh yeah yeah just
sometimes don't put it for space yes
he's waited he's waited it has to be
G can can be capacitated on compensated
I don't care
but it works for copper said yeah what I
was just saying is that yes yeah yeah it
works I and that's actually this is not
a correct statement but this is where
the you know hardness
so if you usually if you can do this
then with some with some tricks with
some high key parallel Ledges and stuff
you can actually deal with weights and
stuff yeah
it's not the correct statement but it
conveys the ideas
okay
that's why I said simplified here
we know how to find
low average spanning trees not
necessarily A trivial problem if the
software is a bit trivial but then if
you want to get down to this quality log
it's even not known if you have a log or
not this is an old problem with many
many works but the important thing is
that you know they exist and then you
can use them sort of as a black box to
this to solve this Oracle question
okay
okay so what are the challenges with
this sort of discuss this one important
thing is that in each iteration of NYU
the problem is that the average load is
good but the worst case load can be very
bad right it can be m
because they can have a cut which is
very dense
and then when I when I wrote along along
that cut that edge will have very high
load so I need n iterations to actually
bring down the thing to load
okay so with spanning trees it seems
like sort of
now let me just cover cover this and
then uh how much time do they have like
two minutes okay
okay
okay so let me just cover this uh what
what we do instead so instead but
actually madre did there's this idea of
embedding into a spelling subgraph of G
instead okay so the intuition is is very
very clear
the intuition is that because average
load is small as I showed
there can't be many edges with high load
okay so if I insist that uh the the
worst case low to be M over J that can
be more than J something right just by
average
or Square depend square root of n it's
easier to think about that
so you take these edges so you somewhat
can identify actually the sages that
have very high load you take all of them
and how do you actually make a low so
let's say these are these blue edges so
how do you make sure that this Edge over
here
has small load or you want to bring it
down back to one how do you make sure
so all of the edges that use this Edge
can be put back in the graph
in this person fire okay that's what's
happening here okay
follow the edges I'm just putting back
they're the same for here right and
actually you know this will induce some
so if you so this F edges are the
critical edges if you delete them from
the tree you will have connected
components right you look all the cuts
induced by these content components and
all the edges that cross these Cuts will
just
be added back okay
so that's the intuition now again I will
not get into this because it's trivial
in a sense it's saying okay instead of H
instead of T I will ask the question for
H
I will say okay can I get a good
Converse combination over spelling
subgraph that is good okay
and now what Madre showed is that for
this problem you can get it and the one
important caveat here is that this F the
number of edges with very high load is
bounded by J not the number of edges
that I put back
okay just the number of edges at the
very high load
okay
now we'll have that the the total
the total load is still good in in this
graph h g is embeddable but that's his
third property not not tells me
something more it says that the worst
case load on every Edge is M over J now
it's not M anymore
so by putting back these edges I managed
to reduce the worst case load but this
load oh this horse is load also bonds
the number of iterations in the multiple
ways update
okay and then you can say okay then I
can find a complex combination of these
graphs and then if you combine these two
running times you will get them squared
over J
the same guarantee right
okay now you might ask
um why is this graph useful
it's not it's far from a j3 right now
okay so what you did you identified some
Milo badges you put back all the edges
that run the cut not useful at all right
you're just putting some edges at random
no idea
okay
so how to turn this into a j3 so after
the decomposition is computed now
individually you will turn this into a
j3 in two rounds
okay round number one is the what's
called portal routing
what is this portal routing now for all
of these edges that were edges in this
connected component right across this
connected component
you will find the unique shortest path
in the tree in the underlying tree
and then take the first vertex that you
hit the end point of f
therefore these edges that these these
edges over here this one and this one
because they were very high load
and take also from from the other end
point also take the the first vertex
that you hit and kind of project this
Edge over here
so you project all of these edges here
okay
so this this is now starting to make
sense
so this can give us something so you
take all of these edges that I put back
randomly right I just put them back to
make the load nice
now I'm doing this projection step
so I I go to from the shortest path from
this guy say to this guy and I have an
edge connecting this too so now what is
the first vertex that I touch that it's
an end point of a high load Edge is this
one right this one over here so I
stopped there I also stop there and now
I can route along along this this one
so this could potentially lead to many
edges here I will have many multiple
parallel edges
okay but now the structure is kind of
nicer it's starting to become nicer it's
still not a j3 but it's close to being a
j3 what's causing them all j3 so what is
this object this gtf it's just a graph
on a tree and plus J edges that's it
nothing else okay
but this is this is starting to become
nicer in a sense and then what Madre can
show is that a simple simulation will
tell you that these graphs in terms of
multi-commodative flow structure are not
far apart they are constant factor for
our part
oh okay
and then
with some very very small lecture where
you can convert this into a j3 but I
will not have time to tell you this and
I'll skip it but you ask me offline and
I can tell you
and how do we make this dynamic
so to make this dynamic
uh we we need to do quite some work in
terms of like a white box in the
construction of Madrid but once that is
set up in a clear way then I I don't
think is very difficult then we'll use
Dynamic tree data structures to do that
so one thing is that this operation of
making something a terminal
uh I could I could be in a very long
path and I want to become a terminal
that's that's bad right then we add
portals we had portals we can throw in J
portals so that you shortcut these
distances into this part so it could be
that you had a very uh very far for
vertex here that wants to become the
terminal then you can shortcut it and
you just add portals to that
and yes there are also some things on
how to maintain this reroute things when
you make something a terminal again uh I
I yes I don't have time to to discuss it
in depth but I'm happy to tell you if
you ask me
okay so let me conclude quickly
um
so one one message from this is that you
can actually maintain g3s dynamically
and this will lead to efficient data
structure for approximating Max flows
and you get truly sublingual update time
as a caveat here is that you will take
login approximation which is which is
not great we want better approximation
but it's fully dynamic and actually the
same exact same approach can be adapted
to dynamical up here shortest path so
you can still do route down letter P do
multiple weights update and then
and that's actually excluded in the
smash Loop that I said
so some of our problems here obvious
over problems can we can we get a better
approximation these things are kept at
Logan so whenever you're going to do
three base approximations you have to
pay the log so new new ideas will be
required maybe with this approach you
can get I don't know you can get higher
approximation and better running time
but still open but in terms of using
similar things to to get better
approximation for Dynamics so it doesn't
seem
like the way to go what about directed
graphs so this is all undirected so
directly expressive bars actually don't
exist
for
three specifiers don't exist
or they exist with very bad
approximation ratio like score defense
and yeah and another question is what
are these J trees or dynamics that
you're useful for
so I'll conclude here thanks and sorry
for going a bit over time
[Music]
[Applause]
okay one quick question for Grandma's
all right then otherwise less than gram
once again
[Applause]
all right